This box sends ultrasonic vibrations
into the air, so that you feel objects
as if they were hanging in thin air.
Now what we're going to do
is try and guess some shapes here okay?
Now this is actually going to create
a noise so we can't talk
whilst you're trying to guess
that shape okay?
Right so what we're going to do
is put the picture on the screen,
so everybody else can see it,
and then I want you to guess if the object
is either a cone or a square.
Okay so they are your two choices.
Okay are we ready?
Alright so, let's just...
[LOUD ELECTRONIC NOISE]
[ELECTRONIC NOISE]
Say that again?
– A cone.
– We think it's a cone.
So can we see?
Yeah and that's what everybody else
can see, it's a cone, excellent, well done!
[APPLAUSE]
So what we have are 256 tiny speakers,
and they're creating ultrasonic vibrations,
so they're outside of the human range
of hearing, so we can't hear them.
But Ethan can feel them.
And in fact that feeling you know when you're near a very loud bass speaker?
So you can feel it in your chest?
So - like that but much
much more precise